hi everyone it's jerry let's have a look
at a game from the 2008 chorus
tournament
on the white end vladimir kramnik
and he's paired against magnus carlsen
the approach carlson takes with his
hedgehog defense is one i hadn't seen
before
with the hedgehog defense you typically
look to play on the queen side you'll
have in mind two key pawn breaks
in this game though
we have king side
aggression
and one of those don't try this at home
type of moves surfaces a move
where you must weigh
its negatives very carefully
so let's hop to it let's get some moves
on
and
if nothing is coming to mind when you
hear hedgehog defense or hedgehog
formation you'll see what that looks
like by move nine
the c5 move is looking to address an
eventual pawn duo
as soon as it's on board
it's going to be eliminated
the little race to get on the long
light diagonal
it's important that black has the bishop
on b7 before the knight has an
opportunity to move and unleash the
bishop to attack the rook directly
mission accomplished here
if black isn't timely
black could be inconvenienced with some
type of knight jump
okay
castles bishop e7
there's the pawn duo and it's
short-lived
the queen recaptures a new piece is
brought to life d1 is vacated this is a
half open file a white rook
definitely wants to be there
small pawn center
is how we describe this setup here
no great weaknesses have been created
with regard to the four center squares
there is however the c6 square to be
mindful of this is a weakness
black has
just created
it's a hole
and a potential outpost can
maybe surface
it's a square that can maybe be
exploited by white maybe a pawn one day
controls c6 that hole and then a knight
is a blink away from getting in there
that could certainly be disruptive
anyhow something to note a weakness
behind that last move
half open file for white and a quick pop
quiz move nine
what move would you play here
feel free to pause the video
okay
this move right here knight c6 i think
would tempt many players
because you're developing a piece with
an attack and that's very often a good
thing but there's reason not to play
knight c6
what's a reason or two
the bishop's eyes want to stay open
black wants to be in a position to
welcome a light square bishop exchange
and you could go one step further
and say
black enjoys retaining some flexibility
with the queen knight
d7
c6
i'm not going to tell you
where i'm going with that knight just
yet
so what does black play
a6 in this here completes
this hedgehog formation this hedgehog
defense
a group of four pawns
on the sixth rank
controlling
six
fifth ranked squares
no
white pieces are going to jump on those
six ranked squares
a6 is controlling b5 keeping a knight
out of b5 securing a queen on c7 and
there's an additional point
b5 is one of the two key pawn breaks i
referenced at the start of this video
and one other one
that i did not appreciate there's one
other idea behind a6 that i did not
appreciate until i viewed this game
uh what is the second
key pawn break it's going to be d5 these
are the two
what do they have in common they're both
striking at white's best pawn this guy
in c4
d5 is almost always going to be the
the main break you want to get in if you
can get it in
to help free your pieces create more
options for your pieces
we have this two to one majority in the
center d5 is
is the main one main one to be on the
lookout for
okay
from here we have knight to g5 so this
is welcoming a light square bishop
exchange
white is okay with giving up their
fiancee bishop
that's a very important
minor piece so if kramnik's going to
if kramernick is welcome to this
exchange what is his justification
well
i believe
what he has his eye on is the weakest
square in black's position or excuse me
the weakest pawn
and that weakest pawn is d6
the d6 pawn is accessible to all
white pieces
the knight on g5
can go to e4 both can go to e4 the
bishop could go to a3 and the majors can
stack themselves on the d file
black needs to take some quick some care
excuse me over d6 that's for sure
knight c6 only now
queen f4 not just to any square
keeps an eye on d6
castles
knight on c to e4
and
another pop quiz
what is carlson's next move
it's a
stockfish 14 is a fan of this next move
feel free to pause the video
okay here we go
knight to e8 when i initially skimmed
through this game this was the first
moment that grabbed my attention that's
definitely different knight to e8
counterintuitive is maybe another way to
describe knight to e8
white enjoys more space in this position
has this further advanced pawn more
freedom of movement for white
when you have this freedom of movement
normally
you know the general general rule says
you really shouldn't be
shouldn't be so welcome to peace
exchanges
and you know when you look at it from
black's perspective
black is a little cramped shouldn't
black be welcome to a knight exchange
instead of retreating like this
what is the justification behind 98 what
is a more
concrete way to look at the knight to e8
move i cited a general rule well
something specifically going on here is
that there's now a battery
released on that g5 knight
and
black is going to look to expand on the
king side he's going to try and
rattle
these posts
of the knights and even the queen
the knight retreat is allowing the f
pawn to advance
but not just yet
e6
would be a vulnerable point
let's get some moves in b3
rook to a7
this is this new thing i learned from
this game that a6 move is allowing this
little maneuver rook a7
to now d7
that's a cool maneuver supporting d6
maybe supporting d5 break
it's worth noting that on
this move right here
instead of the rook lift
black had already considered b5 on this
move
and also this move right here
but
no
no no breaks like that in this game
we're not going to have that b5 or d5
rook a to c1
knight to c7 my initial reaction to this
was oh how clever look at that night
post you're supporting those two typical
breaks
but you know that would definitely not
be a good idea here you'd be unleashing
the rook to see the knight on c6
what is knight on c7 doing it is
supporting the pawn on e6 this is
enabling
black to play f5
scare the knight away and then win
the piece on g5
if black tried to do this right now
knight takes e6 that's gonna hurt
queen's hit
and if black tries to be clever and say
oh i could attack your queen you take my
queen i take your queen
yeah i think that that's working pretty
good for white
threatening mate threatening the queen
black is toast
okay so
knight c7
this next sequence of moves is pretty
interesting right now it's
all these pieces are huddled up
for black seems very cramped
white enjoys more space right
but now
white gets pushed around
white
with this next move goes back to f3
voluntarily
uh alright is anticipating this push so
doesn't want to lose the piece
knight f3 f5 hits
the knight goes back
if the knight's going forward you're
asking for trouble with h6
knight h3 g5 g4 and you're in a fork
one of the knights is going to be
knocked out with check so
you can't go forward
got to go back
g5 this is that
don't try this at home type move
this is the move
you have to weigh
very carefully
look at the gaps that have been created
on h4 h6
f6 all holes
and on top of it all and maybe the first
thing that
crosses my mind when i see g5 it's that
you've opened up this diagonal further
for the bishop that's already on the
main diagonal
you know this kind of stuff starts to
run through my mind
you know the queen bishop battery queen
getting into h8 for me
very scary
so
queen goes back
continues to push g4
and now bishop g5
only move to save material we have a
skewer there you have to play e3
let's pause for a moment that was
a forceful sequence there of four moves
what has
black gained
uh
we i pointed out some of the the
weaknesses right the weaknesses on the
king side the open diagonal
in what way has black benefited
well
this square right here
and this square right here
are now
excellent
posts
for knights
these guys are still a bit off from
getting there but
we can identify both as holes
earlier
you know when i initially made that d6
move i started
may have seemed a little misplaced for
me to be speaking of that c6 square
being a hole
talking about the pawn guarding it we
have this exact exact case right now
in white's house
we have this hole on f3
being controlled by a black pawn now if
only
we could get a black knight there
that will set up
potential
mating nets
that's big trouble for white long term
so
you have to be careful of the f3 square
that's the main
weakness without question
in white's house
okay from here
after that forcing sequence we now enter
a phase of repositioning for each side
we have some maneuvering
needed
so black connects the rooks
white it's off of
an open diagonal
i guess you're also opening up a new
a new square for the knight
mission accomplished with this knight on
c7
it's no longer necessary to defend e6 so
uh we're working on improving our worst
piece this knight right here does not
have yet does not yet have a job
98
maneuvering for white looking at this
opening up that
maybe
opening up a
battery queen bishop battery on that
open diagonal
knight f6
knight f4 have to babysit the e pawn
and after queen to c3
um
one of the
the move that was played here is rook to
g7
uh initially i was thinking to myself in
preparing for this video i was going to
point out this is a move you wouldn't
want to play
but this is actually
a top suggestion by the engine so i
wanted to look
just a couple of moves down the line and
see why that was kind of
a cool thing to do why it was okay to
play that
i thought to myself you wouldn't want to
play e5 because you're giving up this
square on d5
that's a that's a big gap but
black can follow with knight e4
and say to himself you know what i'll
put this bishop on d8
and not only be controlling your knight
but in a way controlling that rook
this guy doesn't have any forward moves
what's this rook really doing
anyhow i wanted to highlight this
setup this is another one of those
proceed with caution type moves e5
there is some benefit of course the main
uh the main benefit
uh black
black obtains in playing e5 is that you
shut down
this diagonal so there is that little
give and take you give up d5 but you
shut down the diagonal
it's another it's another path it is
considered one of the better moves e5
okay in this game
no weakness created this pawn still sits
back
on d6
the rook to g8 this is allowing the
knight to move
so that there isn't going to be a queen
to h8 mate right
hopefully nobody's tempted by knight to
e4 there attacking the queen
that would be the mate and this is this
is the kind of stuff that
you know comes to mind when you have
that g5 move on board
okay so rook g8
and only now knight to e4
queen b3
rook back here so now you can't get into
that you can't you can't make use of c4
anymore
defending e4
or excuse me defending e6 here and queen
to a4 this is where
yeah this is where white starts to go
astray at this point right here i think
one of the
the better moves the computer is
pointing out instead of
instead of even the queen move is this
h4 move
trying to challenge this bishop
maybe flush it back
if
if black is taking well you'll notice
that there's no longer that grip over
the f3 square knight is there to
recapture
uh h4 is considered one of the one of
the better moves in this position
but uh no no no h4 in this game the
queen is eyeing up two weak points on
the queen side
so
white's white's soon going to be winning
a pawn
because of that queen a4 move knight e5
is the follow-up
from here queen takes a6
rook a7
and queen b5 follows you can't take a
second pawn
queen takes b6
would be met with rook on e to b7
queen d4 only move only safe square for
the queen
and after bishop f6 look at this queen
she's in the center but so are these
guys and they're controlling a lot of
her squares she hasn't she has no other
square to go to
the threat here knight f3 with check
and the queen is toast
there's a second threat
let's say let's say white gets out of
the night move with check
the knight still goes there bishop's
defended the other thread is simply a
skewer
if you move the queen there goes the
bishop
at this point
the best would probably probably be to
just give up to give up the queen and
get at least two minor pieces instead of
giving up a clean bishop
all right
so
what am i getting at b6 is
poison queen b5
queens are gone
material is restored black is clearly
better look at these knights
look at this weak square that black
already eyes up the rook is on the
second rank
these pawns are doubled
nothing is really tipping in white's
favor
throwing a check this is not an
inconvenience
some repositioning the bishop is doing
nothing on g5 so some support of e5
i like this next decision by black to
recapture with the pawn
and that means that you still have to
react to this threat
black is not giving let's say white a an
easy way to address this threat by
getting a capture and then there's kind
of a free move
in a way for white many different moves
you could come up with
maybe um but yeah instead it's i'll take
with the pawn and now you gotta do
something with this guy my bishop has an
easier time i'm nice and cozy here the
king is defending it the knight is
defending it you're not even attacking
it you got to do something about that
guy now
so white has to go on the defensive
there's nothing exciting going on on the
eighth rank
one piece there
is not going to be enough
you have to go on the defensive
so battery on the a file
king to g2
there's no longer a queen around to
bother the king so he's stepping up
maybe getting getting off of the back
rank with check
there's really not going to be a safe
square for the king
white is pretty limited with the
different moves he has in this position
yeah tough to suggest really anything
for white this post right here by the
night
is fantastic
it's eyeing up both of these squares in
a knight on these two
f3 or h3 and a rook on g1 that's all
it's really ever going to take to weave
a mating net
so
excellent post for the night
also ready to move the pawn and get the
bishops exchanged
e4 on board look at the grip over that
square
everything's there even if
the knight is captured
upon recapturing there's still
some kind of mating net taking away
these two squares from the king backrank
mates
f3
a big big problem
no doubt
dark square bishops gun
rook a1
tough to really suggest anything for
white initially i thought oh okay you're
going hunting for the b-pawns there's
something more
concerning here
white has to tend to this
doubling on the
on the first rank
that's the big problem so if you were to
go pawn hunting is white
that's going to hurt
what are we doing tonight
if you want to save the night you got to
move the knight but what are we doing
now
no way to stop rook e1 for mate in just
a few
so
poison pawn
the b-pawn again
look at another another role that this
knight has
defending here this is this is maybe the
weakest point in in black's position if
if there's this kind of coordinated
effort on e6 that's no problem it's
covered
so
once more black or white has to retreat
the b pawn is gone
one of the b pawns there's the second
gonzo
and from here we have a passer so we
look to push it
and we are since we're up material we're
welcome to exchanges
so let's see these next
few moves
the b pawn is rolling
knight improves
king g2
rook d7
and we have h3 so if white in this
position is capturing this pawn
we would exchange
and then get to this back rank this is a
cool sequence
how do you how are you stopping me
92 only way
but now we have check king has to go to
the back
the first rank and now discover check
there goes your rook
so what might we say this is indirectly
defended because of that
that uh sequence threatening mate
discovered check nearby
h3
e5
it's it's going to be winning either way
but i just want to emphasize the uh the
preciseness of
the
certain moves right
you could go to the d file or the a file
you're going to the d file
with this rook
so that you have this square covered
you want to be able to flush the knife
back and not deal with the check
it's always a always a reason right
why are we going to the d file instead
the a file in this case
all right
more exchanges
these guys are now doubled and isolated
but it doesn't matter this guy is super
good
controlling the knight
just a couple pieces remaining
knight back to its
wonderful square on f3
pawn is poison rook takes pawn we're
going to have a fork
and after rook to c2
this one's game over
what do you do here
uh white didn't even have a move
if you
well you where you go with the night you
can go back home
you're gonna get mated like that
or if you go to g2 we're capturing the
knight from 8.
brutal that f3 square
so from here after rook to c2 this game
goes no further 57 moves in kramnik
resigns right here
so
what's the story
you have to capture if you want to not
lose any
any more material any more material
straight away
if rook takes rook we recapture
and
if the king comes over like this trying
to get the pawn we can give a check
and then move the knight
and we're promoting next white has to
give up the knight for the pawn soon
enough
and also i guess the last one to look at
is suppose the knight goes here first
well
there are four different ways we can
maybe challenge that knight
we're gonna go to this square right here
where we have pawn support
so we give a check
go here and same story we're going to be
getting the knight for the pawn
like this and go on to win
so yeah an interesting game for sure i
learned a couple different ideas
uh with this one that knight to e8 move
that a6 move
uh seeing a different
reason behind that some
little maneuver with the rook i thought
that's this was very instructive that
committal g5 g4 carving out the f3
square the e4 square
f3 being the big one allowing for these
mating tricks and such
anyhow feel free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you